hi Chris I don't think they're I don't
think we're trying to when I'm in there
trying to pick a nickname for me I don't
have a nickname yeah when you see like
when you see Jim Norton because you know
Jim Norton from the scene I'm sure what
type of nickname so far like some of the
nicknames that have these mics are
terrible by the way pops up for Jim are
tlj who's Fortran II love and Jim it was
very very powerful stories and then what
was the other one
Jim the Freak which is kind of like like
that was the other other one oh the lone
pup no I forgot because let alone pop
because like lone wolf is it's like such
a is a douchey name that they give these
terrorists I said that in high school I
thought I was a lone wolf and it's just
a totally bad name and so I said the
lone pop but he's kind of like you know
he's not exactly I'll be honest when I
think of like nicknames I always think
of like what animal do you look like and
I kind of feel bad but I mean if you
were an animal which animal do you feel
you might most look like oh I haven't
feeling that my thoughts and the fans
thoughts are gonna be remarkably
different right I have a feeling Jim the
worm Norton would win the worm is up
there I'd say the turtles see the worm
the weasel no you're gonna be Jim the
turtle like you have to you're just
specifically sorry anyway you might be
wrong it's kind of a little weasely
Frank Burns Jason yeah the only type of
turtle you look like it had to be a Dee
Sheldon turtle yeah
looks like a D shell right right fragile
when he comes out of the show ya know
real bone or anything he's used to
having a big boom no you're not at all
I'm not I'm Bob I was actually my idea
cuz I'm doing town hall so I'm giving
away some tickets we couldn't think of a
good way to do it so I just come up with
a nickname and I didn't think they were
gonna be konjam the turtle is not bad
but Reese used to call me a mollusk that
was my it is great I figured I don't
know really what a mouth it's a weird
like sea crustacean you're not a
compliment
no it isn't it isn't no what is your
what is your nickname do you find under
the all-american wide
I don't I don't know I don't like I
don't really like it that much but it
was because when I first went to my gym
Madame Raya all those guys I was like
they thought I was like the old American
guy because I married my high school
sweetheart and I don't know they thought
I was good-looking and I had up my iMac
yeah I don't know and then I was a I was
a four time college all-american so the
Homer guy we're gonna call you the
homeric that make apple pie
yeah nice guy yeah apple pie apple pie I
like that yeah you're a nice boy and you
find I want you to what kind of animal
do I look like I need to get picked on
here I don't want to see an animal I
know you guys say you have this some
type of animal everyone looks like an
animal if you really check it out if you
look at them what would you say well you
say Jim which animal do you think I
would say it believe me I'm trying to
think of what animal is ya know cuz I
don't want to count like your big guns
oh you think like an ape I'm going
monkey no you think so
come on Harry enough your loss handsome
muscular a right away orangutan okay
looking at Sam you're not wrong about
that right [ __ ] meetings trust me it
is fun just kind of attack you sir so I
always curious about the fighters
because like I watch wrestling or like
comedy for example where comedians have
to play to the audience Pro Wrestling
like you're playing to the audience
you're putting on this show but like I
always find it odd that in I guess all
sports but specifically in UFC cos it's
a one-on-one competition you guys kind
of have to completely cancel out the
crowd altogether
right I mean I guess if you're really
good at playing to the crowd and being
able to win a fight that's where it's at
like Conor McGregor but I think when
you're really focused on where in the
fighting obviously that's the most
important thing is to win yeah
most guys aren't the greatest that kind
of just playing to the crowd and being
someone who they really
might not be right and and then people
could see that people who could see
fakeness and so it's hard to I can't
pull it off I can't also and start
talking crap or you know being someone
I'm now I'm gonna be myself and and try
to win as many fights I can hey what was
it like fighting in Brazil cuz Colby
Covington just went and he called like
the Brazilians he was like you filthy
animals and I heard but cheetah gave him
a bunch of [ __ ] back like I don't know
if he's playing the bad guy I thought
that like water bottles had been thrown
out over apparently he was just playing
the bad guy oh yeah he's just playing
the bad guy I mean I see what he's doing
I mean like what jail Sonnen did right
yeah years ago pretty much he wasn't and
he wasn't in Brazil when he was doing it
this guy kind of didn't realize I think
what he was saying and the EON was was
killed but he's sticking with it I guess
you had to be consistent and he was
kamek playing the bad boy card for a
long time and he's in Brazil he's got to
stick with it if you don't commit to it
that's as bad as I mean you might as
well it's worse than never saying
anything if you start and then you kind
of back that up a little bit I agree so
I applaud him for having the balls to
stick with that character because he
could have got killed they were throwing
yet I heard that they had to have like
security outside his door they threw it
what did you get [ __ ] thrown at you when
you were walking in ah
no not that I remember I've been grabbed
pretty hard you know as I'm walking I
don't really kind of would ask what
happened I kind of got like a little
idea of what happened with Spacey I know
he came out and basically said that you
know he's been by for a long time he
said that he did something long time ago
he try he get on some 14-year old more
than handsome the a he like picked him
up he was an actor he was 10 was 26 and
the kid was 14 that's like 30 years ago
and they went up they keep it a party
this house and I guess people had left
so space he walked in the key was just
watching TV in his room and space he
picked him up like literally the way you
carry a bride across the threshold
and laid him on the bed and like kind of
was like holding him down and trying to
get with him sexually and then the kid
got up went to the bathroom and then
while I believe it like he didn't yes my
stomach yeah we yeah it was really it
didn't go any further than that but it's
and now this just came out now this
thing pens now 44 50 so yeah
forty-four yeah I'm really good on math
so we're talking about things I was
calculating I was finished you had the
figure fraction I'm okay I've been
practicing like that but yes so like in
an effort to try to calm down the news
of the fact that he tried to molest a
fourteen-year-old boy he was like hey
I'm gay and everybody was like if we
don't we don't care you tried to molest
a 14-gauge normal at this point that
doesn't deflect the real issue here
people pretty pissed off you got me
though because I saw that's all I saw
what's his little thing did you not know
as somebody I don't know Kevin but I
know a lot of people that know him and
I've kind of just known that he was gay
for [ __ ] you know 20 years just you
could see it but is uh did you not know
that as a guy who's like probably
doesn't disgust him that much will you
look at what you surprised to hear that
not really surprised
no no not really surprised but it's not
something I was thinking about or
definitely knew but not surprised yeah
that creepy [ __ ] is the young stuff but
if I had any [ __ ] look at somebody's
that's what I want to know where your
line is
nobody underage and nothing forceful no
I'm a pervert being but not with it's
not because I'm moralistic that's just
not my I mean thank God it's not my turn
on I mean my turn on is different you
know I like I like someone to have a
[ __ ] eye contact with me you know and
to I be enjoying I instantly took my
eyes and I like I like the the feeling
that somebody's enjoying what's
happening it doesn't turn me on earth
enjoy its it doesn't turn me out there
under agent innocent yeah if you take
advantage no I hate that no I want
somebody who's [ __ ] I want somebody
who's got like like I have a lot of
shame so I want somebody who's got like
a lot of shame and then knows how to
shame me I'm a weirdo but I like
somebody who is I mean they know how to
change like they do you want them to
shame you yeah in a way but I want
somebody who knows shames you well
somebody who's dead I want somebody
who's damaged like I'm damaged somebody
who's like who under we understand each
other that many people so you would you
you'd like the gag ball in the mouth on
all fours tied up whipped no I'm not
into being we
the gag ball would kill me cuz my not my
sinuses are so bad I wouldn't want to
breathe I'd panic but you wouldn't be
shamed I feel like a goose like oh come
on guys I feel silly it wouldn't die I
wouldn't do anything for me to be shamed
or whipped but I mean I like an equal
footing thing that's what I kind of like
yeah it's not somebody under age was
like is this okay and then Spacey the
news story today about Spacey is one
some filmmaker who was not underage but
a documentary filmmaker whose name's
Tony Montana said that Kevin came up to
him in a bar and he grabbed his he
grabbed his whole package his dick and
his balls and then Kevin said this
designates ownership it is a weird thing
to have somebody say when they grab your
penis because this designates ownership
that's a lot of that's a long thing to
say when you're holding a penis
well after that Harvey Weinstein thing
did another act to come out that was his
name I'm so bad with names but one of
these actors came out and he was at a
party and I guess one of the and he was
there with his wife and one of these
producers like big-time producers came
over to him and grabbed him by the hair
Cruz Terry Crews yes yes it makes even
better he's like the most intimidating
looking guy ever yeah and there's
probably this little white guy goes up
to him and grabs him by the schlong and
basically just and then walks away I
think right is that the story yeah he
just had to take it how do you grab a
guy guess a guy like that in front of
his wife like what do you thinks gonna
happen reaction has to be to punch the
guy instantly they put some well the
Pens are who he is I mean my career is
not that good I mean I don't fly punch
him or not I don't have really a lot
going on in show business you would
allow somebody to do an action the
designates ownership to you I don't who
he was and what he could offer me no
that would freak me out to being grabbed
like that would freak me out
well like when you're on the way of the
Octagon and somebody grabbed me by the
dick yeah just just grabs you in general
like is there sort of because you're I'm
assuming you're on such like a high like
level you're ready to fight at any you
know within seconds like is there a part
of you that wants to turn around and
swing at somebody but you have to yeah
like you're so you're so focused at that
point so you have to you already know
any of any type of distractions that
come as you walk out you got to just
tune out you know whatever people are
screaming yourself but as soon as
grabs you it's a different feel right
security guards are supposed to be
keeping these guys back and so when you
get grabbed by the arm and pulled well
you actually you kind of lose your
balance it does kind of flush it flush
you wanna throw an elbow yeah you like
you know hit this guy but it happened
maybe once pretty bad I just had to keep
on moving yeah your and your and your
promoting 217 this Saturday here in in
New York and it's one of the Madison
Square [ __ ] amazing it's one of the
best cards ever the main event is
Michael Bisping is fighting GSP who's
coming back after it's a huge fight it
is a big fight but the other ones Kody
guarding is TJ Dillashaw
the and J chickens Rose namajunas who I
love and also uh like I think the second
fight on the card is uh his brother all
right Steven Thompson against Jorge Mass
Fidel which is gonna be an incredible
fight crazy crazy card how is he doing
he's like the nicest guy ever he is the
nicest guy he's doing really good
there's a huge fight for him I mean who
is it Jorge Oh Jorge Jorge I think it's
were hey master okay yeah so Hawaii is
one of these dudes I mean he was
fighting on the streets for money the
Miami fights used to do like those uh
the things that Kimbo Slice would do and
what was his name Donna five thousand so
he was doing those backyard Street yes
so this guy's like definitely a tough
dude he has more of a traditional like
more Thai stance moving forward very
well well-rounded but one the boy when
he's on his feet that's his world that's
where he gets whole life he's been
fighting guys like Jorge so I think it's
gonna be a really good fight for him
yeah it's funny that those backyard
fighter guys there isn't mystique with
them because there's that's just such a
raw way to come up you just I guess they
would have gloves wouldn't it wouldn't
be sometimes they taped their hands a
little bit but those you see hand
doesn't bring immediately I knew a guy
whose first fight is the glove that he
used was it was it made of cardboard
oh God Brendan Steiners Mariano Rivera
stories first glove was a fireboard okay
this guy Brendan Steiner we like I go
yeah we do like him a lot he's a
memorabilia dealer but he's been in this
studio no Dino sports
yes dinosaur yeah it's his son or
something no I know he's a Guinan but
how old the guy who started Steiner
Sports is he's probably like in his
fifties a fighter
nope making fun of him my face
he's been in here know you guys are
comedians no he's been in here no no
fewer than half a dozen times and every
time he comes in he tells the story
about Mariano Rivera using a cardboard
baseball glove and again the first time
it's like oh wow in this sixth time it's
like yeah we know no see right there's a
picture Rivera that's how fun of him
with that we always try to like lead him
into the story to see starts we know the
look all right already we know that's
that's what we're very aware on his hand
you you watch other sports to know a lot
of fighters don't like Matt might be
unfiltered partners literally become one
of my favorite people Matt Serra is my
best I love them there's no lying in
Matt Serra no like you guys are you guys
are two peas in a pod with that I don't
say you look you don't lie much to you
not really to myself a lot in the mirror
like you'll have a family someday yeah
your success I want to thank everybody
for the sellout for papering the room
you know Matt's a brutally uh a brutally
honest guy he's a fun guy to to to work
with because it's just no [ __ ] at
him people loves you he's just a raw guy
but you guys don't know he's like I
don't want your anything with a ball he
can't watch any other sports other than
fighting didn't like them he didn't like
brawl playing it he's just never was
into sports really crazy he was a
martial artist he was you know gotten to
I think maybe jujitsu first or karate
something maybe karate first and I got
into jujitsu but does he think they're
stupid like it doesn't make it to say
one thing I love Matt but he's not good
at them and that's really long ago just
kills him with that I mean the guy can't
hit a ball for his life he can't throw a
weekend I'm like that's a guy I actually
got in the cage and win it's crazy and
when your fight you I always hate when
people give me instructions and people
are yelling instructions do you actually
listen and is it helpful I will always
get him back with it going when coaches
and stuff and and trainers humility when
I'd be playing Little League and like it
would be like alright Jimmy just choked
up I shut up
yeah it's not humiliating he's so fast
we need mullets right there
I thought I was I would be so
embarrassed when people give me a stir
but you actually find it helpful or do
you like not listen no I do I do listen
you know it's like these the voices that
used to hearing every single time you're
in practice and you're sparring it kind
of just gets filtered in there and you
that's the only voices you really hear
well every once in a while you'll like
hear something rant the completely
random or you'll see somebody in the
stands and as you're like ground them
pounding somebody I wonder what he's
thinking right now you look like weird
random thoughts like that but other than
that and kind of just hear your coaches
how you ever seen a celebrity in the
audience or somebody that you knew oh
yeah yeah oh yeah like while you're
fighting and it registered I try I think
there's a bunch of times where I've seen
like Joe Rogan and I'm like punching and
whatever I'm doing and I'm like I wonder
what he's saying right now about me it
doesn't distract you it's just a weird
thought yes it's like a weird random
thought that somehow I remembered this
buy more but just actually that I'm able
to think about afterwards and but weird
do you ever have like does the audience
ever is there a celebrity or somebody in
the audience that you're like I don't
want to see that let that person see me
hit my ass kicked like I really like now
yeah I mean I remember Arnold Arnold was
that one of my fights Schwarzenegger
yeah Terminator and I did not want to I
don't want to lose I want him to think I
was good why did you in no I want one
yeah and we went out we went out to
dinner and there was a falling out with
him like three four times now I am a big
time
I've only met him once and he seemed he
was he was nicer than I thought he would
be what are you talking about with
Schwarzenegger well the first time I
really met with him it was the most
scary thing ever I was at the Arnold
Classic one of those you know
bodybuilding contests that he runs and I
was doing something for a sponsor and he
had someone got in touch with my manager
at the time and was like hey Arnold
wants to meet you and I'm like all right
okay yeah I'm cool with that and I'm
kind of crapping my pants and he said
I'm meeting this Lobby and he comes and
this is right after he was just got
dumping the governor he he comes in and
he's got like you know eight-eight like
security dudes around him and he's
walking towards me now he's his eyes
have you know caught me and he's just
walking towards me and I'm just like the
Terminator is staring at me and walking
towards me and I was the weirdest thing
ever
I was so starstruck you are right yeah
and then since then when we hung out a
couple of times after that but it was I
was I was kind of just asked him for
advice I mean I was asking him things
like how did he
you know start like marketing himself
the way he did I mean he was a
bodybuilder how did he become this movie
star right and he and his English was
good but it was choppy at a very very
heavy accent so it's okay how do you
break into it to it to movies when a
politician in America is a broken
English I mean that's hard
What did he say when you asked how
broken so he said he said he got into
marketing he like went to school and
started learning about like how to
market stuff because he loved
bodybuilding so much but no one else
cared about it yeah so he's like I don't
understand why all these people don't
like it so I'm gonna show him you know
why why I love it and what he said he he
said he did was he realized that all
these people who got interviewed who are
bodybuilders they would always be like
oh you know I trained like six times a
day
I'm so tired you know eat like 20 meals
a day and it was just like negative and
boring so he was like instead I wanted
to like bring good energy to it and you
just said stuff like it makes me like
when I get this plump it makes me want
to come like it's better than coming or
whatever you say he said he did like
awesome he did like this and he
literally just started like talking
about how much he just loved it it
prepared to sex I know that documentary
from the 70s yeah but I didn't know that
he compared it to coming oh yeah he
literally is like yeah he's like this is
they said it's like coming when you get
a pump on it's coming it's probably not
oh wow oh yeah headphones course if you
know the greatest feeling you can get in
a gym mode the most satisfying feeling
you can get in the gym is the pump let's
say you train your biceps blood is
rushing into your muscles and that's
what we call the pump you muscles get a
really tight feeling like your skin is
going to explode any minute you know
it's really tight it's like somebody
blowing air into into your must let's
just blows up and it feels different it
feels fantastic
it's coming it's coming coming is you
know I said having sex with a woman and
coming having sex with you amazing try
getting the feeling of coming in the gym
I'm getting the feeling of coming at how
am I getting the feeling of coming
backstage when I'd pump up when I bows
out in front of 5000 people I get the
same feeling so I'm coming day and night
that should have been his campaign
slogan yeah when I'm helping California
it makes me feel like I'm coming oh
that's great so we got people excited
about bodybuilding yeah I favor those
yeah I never saw that actually but I
mean I forgot that he had awesome he had
done that documentary in the 70s wow
what a great way to pop coming
everywhere I guess they compare weird
things like my father used to run
marathons and he said he'd ever said
it's like coming that would creep me out
like that why do you run so much like
jetting Jim run with me no he said it's
like he said but you get high goes you
get a runner's high
like from running you get like it's
almost like a stoned feeling of
endorphins I've never gotten that from
from working yeah I get it from
performing once in a while I can
endorphin rush and I guess it is like
it's better than a relationship I would
say it's not better than sex but I
understand the comparison but just not
in physical activities well you've never
gone and gotten a pump on
I have not do you see his muscles though
oh yeah yeah the big giant veins yeah
and some blue that's got to feel good to
look at your body and realize you've
done that it does I don't feel as good
no no no I don't know I don't me neither
you trained your body into a temple Jim
I have I put weight on immediately you
should have seen Jim who's gotten naked
pictures of Arnold everywhere yeah Jim
Jim was gaining four pounds for a movie
role that's like seven and he was big
they asked you to gain weight they're
like oh so you know they gave me a part
and I didn't they didn't need to ask me
I kind of just wanted to do it and I
know I said choice yeah I had a limited
time to do it but he like you've never
seen a guy binge eat the way Jim does I
swear one it was only over the course
like a week
one morning for breakfast he had a bagel
with cream cheese and then three donuts
and a diet coke yeah cool em I'll have
the coke if you're getting away I don't
like coke I like a diet coke but your
body takes it makes you fat anyway like
the body just goes right this is cool so
you just wanted to be fatter you don't
want like more muscle and oh no no no no
I just wanted to put weight I want it to
be jolly or under the neck which I was a
little too skinny so I when they made my
shirt I had them I'm like I had to go
for a special fitting I'm like put it up
and [ __ ] choke me with it really so it
pushes my neck out so I look a little
bit it feels like coming yeah they're
coming a little bit yeah I mean again if
I had to find a month I could have
really done it but I said I want to feel
like I'm coming under said I want to
feel like I'm control and you make my
day you did marry your high school
sweetheart too is that we like all of a
sudden you're really famous you could
okay people love you
so obviously women are hitting on you
how do you like go like hey man that's
not the way I Wow
now you try and get me killed no no no
because you've obviously a happily
married guy so what in your mind goes
that's not what I want
uh I guess I just I was programmed to no
guy stay away from that that's not good
and I just know it's all trouble you
learn from other people's mistakes you
don't want to get caught and so that
life yes there's so many ways to get
caught now because it's like you know a
years ago you could cheat all over the
place of two families but now
everything's on a computer or social
media and you know you're finished yeah
and you know what's funny yet yeah and
actually never mind I was a Matt Serra
quote and then I'm right you know laser
focus where you you've got you've got a
task at hand you're married dude you're
not [ __ ] around you're not partying
you're not doing sterile you're not
doing any of this that you're doing what
you're supposed to be doing because it
comes with the job right it comes with
the territory
does it then like is it even more
confusing to you than the rest of us
when you hear like stories like Jon
Jones for example who's like he just
can't get his [ __ ] together like he
can't stop [ __ ] and doing drugs and I
don't care about the drugs and all that
stuff because listen that's just part of
life not that I'd do it but I'm just
doing it's just yeah yeah but the
steroids thing because listen we're
getting okay
another guy and you're looking to hurt
the other guy and to go in there
basically with a weapon that the other
guy can see and it's not allowed to use
that's that's not cool
yeah because on some level even though
you're hurting each other like you have
to trust the guy that you're across the
cage from yeah and and and everyone's
like oh you know he's he's a he's such a
freak you know look at him Baba but then
the day is he a freak or is he a guy who
was on steroids for his whole career we
don't know I mean if I was on steroids I
guarantee you guys would think I'm a
freak even though I'm a freak even
without it but I'd be even more of a
freak
yeah it's message of the game the two
are weird like like Jesse Taylor who's a
guy who kind of who who was I think in
the Ultimate Fighter house and he was
like doing very very well and then I
think he won or he came in he got drunk
and he [ __ ] up and Dana wouldn't let
him for he was gonna fight in the finals
and Dana yanked him because he was
causing a big problem publicly so he
comes back and he's about to about to
fight again or he fights again and then
they test positive for something it was
a dick pill and said the dick pills are
I think I'm saying there's a Jesse
Taylor Josh it was okay so viagra not
viagra no and over-the-counter one but
how are these viagra actually truly have
stuff that you can fail for do you know
I don't know but some of the organic
might it's the gas station great know
they're using nominal you think the dick
pill thing is [ __ ] I don't I'm gonna
say I don't think that guys aren't using
dick pills because I know plenty of guys
do I would never but oh yeah but I don't
think that's why they're failing I think
they're using that as a cover-up I know
John Jones had used that as a cover up
once and now I think he probably has
another cover for it because he failed
again but a lot of guys are like getting
these supplements they find after they
fail they find they have their
management and other team you know find
out supplements that could possibly be
tainted oh I was taking this okay 7sm
and now look oh it was tainted so that's
what yeah I mean we can't say he wasn't
taking this because it is something you
could get we're somewhere so it caused
enough doubt into the thing even though
you didn't disclose it even as one of
your supplements you know that's that's
the other thing if you did take a dick
pill
you should disclose it right because I
fighters who've taken that and they get
drug tested and they don't fail so
there's a good John Jones was lying
about it the first time because yeah
obviously he was lying about a bunch of
stuff that he but how could he be so
silly this is the thing with joy like
the test he was in competition test I
mean it was like right around the time
like like if you took it then it
wouldn't even have helped you and and he
knows how they test like why the [ __ ]
would he have done it's just insanity
well what's it at it was after the fight
he failed of the day of the fight I I
think the the second favorite year was
this most recent whiner right after the
fight it was right after I don't know
man I I just don't I don't I don't know
I feel like there's some guys who have
like doctors and they like take them off
things and the manage your blood somehow
and their urine and know exactly when
they're gonna pass or fail and maybe a
miscalculation I don't know okay it's
crazy is it tempting at all I mean I
know you don't do it but is it a
tempting thing like [ __ ] man I'm tired I
should I should do something or do you
just like it's is it just not even a
thought that would crush it first of all
I for me I got I got a five-year-old boy
gun you know I got kids and I don't want
to ever wake up and have to explain to
them that you know the dad cheated
because they're gonna be hearing from
their kids their friends in school and
like why it was okay for me to cheat but
they're not about a cheap I don't want
that's like one of the biggest things at
this point it was always like you know I
don't want to I don't want to cheat you
know I don't want to cheat these other
guys I'm hoping I'm cheating and I wanna
I don't wanna I don't want to do it do
that but then it becomes all somes like
you know I don't want to let my kids
down and my family down so you do think
that I don't have kids so the kids
actually kind of come into your
mentality I definitely I don't want to
let them down I look like a good guy
yeah I mean we yeah when you have a kid
it's like all of a sudden you there is a
responsibility for your actions that
wasn't there before somebody's watching
everything that you do not necessarily
in a negative way it's just there's a
personal responsibility not just to
raise the kid but to do things that you
would tell the kid to do and not do
things that you would not have the kid
do right yeah and then also like if they
were gonna if if there's drug testing I
just don't I wish they could figure out
a way to where you can't take these
steroids because obviously guys are
still doing it and if they're gonna let
people take steroids the thing that
sucks about that obviously then I would
do it if everybody's doing steroids then
but the problem is they're not good for
you like you're literally gonna possibly
die early and all this crap and then
guys are gonna take several ways to a
whole nother level some of these guys
before the use Dada which is
out of control though you get tits if
you come off him too like that like I
know kind of blockers they are but if
you come off and then don't you get like
breasts because uh like you like that
like they they they the testosterone
block or whatever it is yeah you have to
get the estrogen blockers as you're
coming off of them I think oh that's why
when people get like popped for estrogen
block I think things Rock got popped for
an estrogen blocker yep channels - I
thought it was Chiana that nothing share
some baseball players yeah no that's
like a thing you don't rest because they
come off the Sasha and they don't like
bring that extra estrogen back down I
don't know anything about that stuff I
obviously I've been I always thought
like should I take a little block guys
everything you're taking steroids I've
thought of it but not being a big but
just can I'm always so tired my sleep
Sox how do you want all he does is
[ __ ] come that's a savage guy like
that to me he lives in ideal life he's a
happily married guy he likes to have sex
he likes to fight TRT with trt helped me
get a little energy s Matt Serra he's
gonna say yes okay you know as I was
like as soon as trt came out of my gap
after I'm done fighting I'm definitely
doing it and then I'm hearing all these
guys they're just like you know they
have to have to do it for the rest of
your life at least in a week I think you
have to take injections every single
every single week for the rest you what
if you don't like an 80 years old you're
still injecting yourself and get titties
and how much how much studies are into
how long I mean how long is trt really
been around to where their studies on it
like how you gonna are you gonna live to
your 80 right now so yeah maybe I won't
I don't wanna hear either I'm smooth and
hairless and a lot of girls like that
like the fact I'm not a hairy guy so I
don't start sprouting hair 49 years old
it's creepy to be 49 sprout hair when
you start doing link I know that there's
like a trend now people some people just
do it cuz they get hung over but the you
get the IV like the vitamin IV you know
that's like we're not a lot of good IVs
mhm ever now
I guess because cyclists like you know
cycle out their blood
somehow I see so we're not allowed IV is
that what do I do in cycling out all
their blood supposedly that's why they
banned IVs originally was because cycler
in between there whatever races they'll
go into a little you know little
dormitories wherever they go and they
would start doing IVs 2-cycle like
basically blood transfusion I think like
taking their blood and put in clean
blood I don't know that's basically that
they just got rid of IVs altogether
because they don't want to worry about
that but they don't put it sorry can you
put it through somewhere else they're
gonna check your arm in the back here
nemeth onto other veins you can use you
I think you'd Aaron's they say that they
attach to the plastic like the plastic
plasticity or something in your blood
and also maybe you've been taking an IV
but don't buy I think they're not
looking for needle holes I would yeah
well if I had money I would get that IV
I have a guy coming to my house once a
week twice a week whatever I could
afford to give me the IV oh my friend
gets all the time it's like 400 bucks
and any time he feels like he's getting
a little sick do that and there's
different things like you feel you
getting the flu there's like a different
type of cocktail they make if you feel
you know if you're just out drinking the
night before yeah pepper cocktail it's
all like suicide they cycle out your
blood no no no this is like it's
literally like a bag IV bag like you're
in the hospital and a bunch of water
going into you yeah and so if you're
hungover the big issue is that you're
dehydrated so basically they hydrate you
yeah because you're not gonna be able to
drink when you you know so that's really
why and you can have them come to your
house yeah like that cuz pee I would do
yeah I know a lot of people hadn't done
it and it's been like everybody loves it
oh I didn't know that I guess I'll just
type in a doctor or something yes they
bring an IV and it's either how long
does it take I mean it's pretty quick
and it's like legit nurse legit nurse
comes and they say with you and
everything less than an hour
bag is empty and it's either rehydrating
or it's like just vitamins and there's
there's a website it's like the [ __ ]
nurse they come and they they do it in
their trainees it's pretty awesome
are they really yeah he doesn't want to
do the radio show anymore yeah he wants
to go he wants a good night at training
diner right now
yeah I didn't know your talked about oh
my god is that really a website it could
be in this day and age sure delightfully
young nurse what have you ever you
should do a growth hormone how you talk
about doing that no don't do that yeah I
don't know a lot of guys done it but
they work out like these are guys who
have committed to these guys with the
huge bellies weird like all their
insides have grown from the inside out
and it just pushes their stomach out
that's obviously not good yeah don't you
have any cancer cells in your body at
all it's just if you have any cancer
cells in your body I keep going away
from the medica it just I guess it just
gets bigger and bigger so how really
scary stuff the vitamins oh that makes
it that makes some vitamin C vitamin
that's healthy right yeah I'll make you
feel good for the day is jacked but it
lasts only for a day yet they think I'm
in IV and until vitamins run out right
wait until you would dehydrate again
like you know some b12 and vitamin C
you'll feel good